pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
hu
voilà voilà voilà aux ados ah c'est toi
monique oui non ça tombe bien parce que
j'allais de téléphoner un nom sortira
toujours bien sûr c'est mon jeu je ne
peux pas venir à paris n'ont pas pu
venir parce que j'ai un rendez vous non
non je peux pas venir non j'ai trop de
travail
c'est la bonne c'est là c'est la bonne
solution
oh ça c'est la bonne solution oh non
c'est que c'était la bonne jeudi c'était
la bonne
j'ai dit c'est là c'est elle c'est la
bonne solution oui je crois comme vous
avez envisagé vraiment une bonne c'est
une bonne solution et je pense un nom
c'était la bonne
oui mais je peux pas faire retourneur un
compas un péché terre sur boule obut
passait pas de salon un nom mais ne sera
pas là je lui donnais ce week-end merci
elles sortent en comptant pas bon alors
tu peux venir ici on passera week-end
avec un voile à bon terme statique le
chemin vieux crayon papier
bon voilà alors tu vas jusqu'à lisieux
voilà à lisieux et connaît là tu prends
un départ le mental 80 89 voix l'a89 oui
et alors là après le départ 20 89 tu as
un petit village à peu près à 10 km oui
dit qu'il aurait dû d'après l'iata une
maison blanche la grande maison blanche
c'est pas celle là après la maison
blanche une grande avenue gay en sens
interdit
alors suis pas celle là non plus et
l'autre après voilà quand tu la prends
tu as tout droite ou la gauche est bien
sûr deux fois à droite 2 soit tu peux
pas te tromper de paris c'est tout droit
vers une grande maison avec une grande
dune gangate a qu'à pousser la grille
puis voilà comment un chien voyez votre
chien bâtir la maison
les patineurs
planter un jeu léché qui ronge notre nom
sur mon tapis rouge d'autres gilbert
château ce nom et votre chien voilà on
répète oui oui la maison c'est ça deux
fois à droite et tu pousses avec voilà
mais non tu es à votre chien ne
t'inquiète pas voilà un oui il faut vite
aller en bas je te mords je te mords
temps brad we partout partout partout
partout à voir money bon maintenant
suzanne des croisades
oui je pense que ne met pas travailler
dimanche
non messieurs et les structures non plus
d'ailleurs
ben je me donne de bonnes week-end à mes
amis c'est ce dimanche jour de congé je
sais déjà que je suis je fais mais je
vous donne le dimanche en plus voilà et
6 heures du soir vous êtes riches
jusqu'à lundi matin
tout frais - mais je suis pas égoïste
moi je pense aux enfants
et ben oui mais non à la marge inquiétez
pas je me débrouille très bien tout seul
merci monsieur messier bien finir mais
cela mal de choses temps en temps je
veux bien me sentir libre
je pense que c'est la même chose pour
vous parle oui voilà alors seize
parcelles firent décret voilà et masques
andré bec soleil se bâtir une bonne idée
ça cale terrasse et la terrasse au
travail monsieur d'habitude congo
comptait rester ici pour le week-end
gilbert n'ai pas l'intention de sortir
maintenant pourquoi faire pour aller
respirer la pure la campagne
oui oui elle est alors allé à la ville
allait voir tronquent la les yeux ah ben
non parce que je dis donc c'est son jour
de plus grosses recettes
les gens qui n'ont cure est un bon eh
bien allez je vais pas m'en aller
allez voir votre petite amie vous aviez
vous avez un petit ami un oui mais en ce
moment il fait son service militaire à
tahiti et puis d'ailleurs il a trouvé
là-bas quelqu'un pour le remplacer il va
des pieds une quoi mais vous savez ces
filles qui dansent avec des colliers de
fleurs sur le vent à une vahiné we said
une faillite et qui bannit bombe est
alors allée font mal et le aller au
cinéma voilà aller au cinéma en peine on
préfère les romans photos jamais atteint
dans ma semble alors cio non sans des
crêpes et de masse contre un vaste hall
n ont raconté que des six ans je viens
vous donnez votre votre repos mais moi
je veux pas correct est ici mais aussi
quelques failles mais je sais pas allez
vous faire bronzer ailleurs eu deux
pourvu que vous ne restiez par la maison
c'est tout
ah bon je serai seul avec monsieur peur
comme voyons que vous allez chercher ce
jeune homme sérieux mais pas du tout
d'où le nom mais temps en temps on
écrivait as besoin de solitude pour
écrire c'est tout après si tu me oui
j'ai tout allait aller vous allez faire
votre valise le cas pendant 10 minutes
vous me traite dans votre petit bikini
je ne me sens pas de bikini moi non bbc
enfin vous me faites votre valise valeo
costea dans la grille et blanc prendre
le car pour religieux ces gens là vous
prendrez le train pour eux pour
deauville ou pas c'est un excellent
week-end bien masqué attendez attendez
attendez ce n'est pas mille fois mais
c'est pour le car le train la chambre
d'hôtel s'il a quelque chose je
regarderai tout de même monsieur ça
coûte certes d'être écrivain
une fois de plus de 10 en finale
l'atome excusez moi l'émotion
enfin bruno toison quelqu'un au ya
quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un ou la personne
hélas emile mais c'est pas entendu la
sonnerie de la gagne belle ouverte avant
alors comment tu vas y faisait bon mais
alors je me suis dit que j'allais faire
un saut jusqu'ici met une très bonne
idée
et puis dîner avec toi c'était une moins
bonne idée et patient week-end entre
amis
c'est une très mauvaise idée vicky est
folle de joie vite à l'idée de passer
trois jours à la campagne qui vit qui je
te présente mon ami papilles de villars
tir vie qui vaille le jeune comédien
géant messieurs
je suis ravie de faire votre
connaissance j'aime beaucoup ce que vous
écrivez
oui moi aussi
soit je dis moi aussi je suis ravi de
vous connaître malheureusement emile a
mal choisi en menant à ça tu peux dire
alors prendre la roue d'un samedi ça
n'est pas très amusant enfin
heureusement maintenant on va avoir le
temps de se reposer mal c'est pourquoi
pas ici et tout depuis tant qu'on se
connaît un peu gêné et c'est justement
on va s'gêner bas avions l'air pur
l'odeur de la campagne que je te dise
rien que de respirer ça me donne faim
mais il va s'attendre intense carrière
manger d'un côté vous allez voir un
verre en vitesse et puis d'aller manger
dans une auberge des ambiances le tigre
est une excellente adresse
il n'en est pas question je te ferai
jamais un truc pareil on va dîner ici
que tu te dis que c'est pas possible je
vais t'expliquer nous mais ne t'inquiète
pas ta femme a tout prévu
non mais le délai soit 23h à l'aise dans
la voiture
quelle voiture à la mienne je suis venu
avec avec ma femme de ta voiture avec
les deux noms de dieux de nom de dieu
mais le prix mais n'atteignant mais ne
t'énerve pas je te dis que tu n'auras
rien à faire ils vont s'occuper to move
est pas demandé de venir avec ma femme
mon papa il va belber pendant que y
était mais elle est là mon vieux quoi
je te dis que j'ai pensé à tous au
boulot d'open tv vous bat ajoie et
patati patata
voici comment je vais m'en tirer mois
maintenant visions noircies
l'occident excellente idée pas si nous
placent effet de dilution vaudrait saint
yves
alors comme ça vous comptez passer le
week-end ici évidemment ça a pas l'air
de faire plaisir mais si malheureusement
vous ne pourrez pas pourquoi mais parce
que je dois rester seul pourquoi parce
que je dois personne humaine pagnoux
surtout pas vous voilà la ola mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
explique mais je dois rester ça parce
que je suis parce que t'es quoi je suis
je suis je suis
mais t'es quoi faire et quoi je suis je
suis contagieux contagieux malade malade
comme une bête mais il faut appeler le
vétérinaire compte enchaîner mais qu'est
ce que tu as mon pauvre sauver la grippe
le rythme à prendre ne bouge pas ou la
vie quand ils m'appellent de réveiller
des frissons partout la tête comme une
citrouille
c'est la gueule de bois dont alors la
grippe en plein match jointe ça ça fait
penser à la couche sur wii
non j'ai entendu à la radio que la
veille depuis des beats grippe asiatique
dans la région alors j'ai dû forcément
la trappe et c'est normal la jeep lancia
vigan mon dieu mon père a failli en
mourir
il est pas beau nom mais il est resté
très diminuée c'était avant ou après
votre naissance après côtoieront comme
ça
tu as fait un médecin louis n'est pas
question de voir avec ça ce que je veux
c'est rester seul site où te laisser
seul quand tu es malade chez fauchon
suzanne
enfin madame bizarre oui monsieur m'a de
réponse et je vais passer le week end à
deauville au nom non il faut vous
restiez j'aurai besoin de vous vous
voyez vous madame moi ce n'est pas
tellement mais comme monsieur insisté en
fait monsieur les billets des billets un
des billets mais voulez vous des billets
vous voulez vous les gardez les billets
vont vous servir une autre steve wallace
et les billets volés garde qu'elle y est
kabyle est appliquée levier cabinet des
milliers de billets tu viens tu avais
donné pour pour prendre le cas pour
aller jusqu'à la gare de lisieux et là
ils auraient pris le train après pour
aller jusqu'à deauville week end à
deauville c'est toi qui lui avait mis
cette idée dans la tête me mais mon
pauvre chéri mais ça ça lui aurait coûté
au moins 500 francs donc ça tu croit
évidemment on voit que c'est pas toi qui
fais non non non puisque tu ne veux pas
a rappelé le médecin
on va on voit te faire une piqûre j'ai
toujours des antibiotiques à la maison
orange on ne veut pas des firmes et non
plus mais je préfère les piqûres si vous
voulez vous mais bien sûr avant d'être
comédienne j'ai passé mon diplôme
d'infirmière vous en avait déjà fait
mais bien venir c'est la première chose
qu'on apprend on s'entraîne sur des
biftecks son débit fixe
c'est parfait on a tout ce qu'il faut
comment tout ça roule plus en plus pâles
bon vous l'avez dit on va tout préparé
tu viens maman j'étais allé aussi nom
reste la norme g a parlé on est content
de toi ben oui ça va les affaires sont
dit je me fous de des affaires et
reprendre tu voulais parler ma santé bah
oui ça madame un véhicule mais ça me
fout de ta santé aussi
alors tu te fous tout mais alors
pourquoi tu veux rentrer je suis content
que lens était content de venir [ __ ]
la pagaille qui moi ou c'est ici dans ma
maison
comment j'attends une fille qui doit
venir dans une ère passer le week-end
avec moi tu peux pas le dire tout de
suite au lieu de faire des cachotteries
c'est pas difficile de bien léché
si la mairie sera bien sûr c'est pas mon
directeur de conscience ils ont gaita
femme arabe a quand même bien compris oh
là là quelle histoire part j'avais tout
combiner tout préparé du départ qui s'y
est ma femme et ma belle-mère à dillon
téléphone lui tout type de ne pas venir
c'est pas possible et déjà vous ou là et
c'est nathalie non non non brigitte
menon se finit avec ses collègues il
annonce une nouvelle que la connaît face
les monique encore une nouvelle
après lyon qu'est-ce que tu as comme
matériel
c'est pas du neuf et de l'occasion en
mars et dure moins longtemps par semaine
quand même trompé sa femme si souvent je
t'en prie et par des boîtes et j'te pull
de conscience mais dis donc ça fait
combien de temps que tu la trompe sommes
mariés depuis 15 ans donc je te demande
pas depuis combien de temps tu es marié
je te demande depuis combien de temps tu
la trouves tu viens je vais te le dire
quinze ans
mais alors pourquoi tu l'a épousée parce
que j'ai des noms et c'est parce que tu
lèves que tu la trouves tu tiens vaut la
peine de hurler comme ça pour tout le
monde le sache non d'abord un mari
trompé sa femme quand il a une maîtresse
attitrée parc athéna plusieurs je vois
pas la différence à quand on est capable
de passer une nuit entière sans toucher
sa maîtresse là on trouve sa femme parce
qu'enfin une femme légitime au bout de
quelques adn s'attend pas à ce que tous
les soirs bon alors si on agit de la
même manière avec sa maîtresse
on trompe sa femme puisqu'on se conduit
avec une autre comme ab kanaat eu l'idée
intéressante oui mais l'aviron dans
toutes ces filles en a jamais eu et il a
demandé le divorce et pour l'épouser un
honneur revient toujours que je ne
quitterai jamais ma faim ah bon qu'est
ce que tu leur dis mais je le raconte
que noël à une maladie de coeur ont fait
pas ça une cardiaque une maladie qu en
langue là tu vas un peu fort a rétabli
trouver quelque chose non maintenant tu
vois doit donc être les tracts du même
avis mais moi je savais pas brava oui
mais non tu sais toi d'en sortir
moi je peux pas savoir moi je viens chez
toi et mais justement on débarque pas
chez quelqu'un qui passait le week-end à
la campagne les hôtes hier teinte amené
ta femme
enfin ça se fait pas tu te rends compte
non et avec sa petite amie quand tu le
marché que ce qu'elle fait à tomic ils
n'ont pas mis qui victime et qui dit qui
y est c'est une actrice de talent en
battant en train d'apparaître parking
bas par les pubs par mois bah oui
et comme insectes et banquiers j'espère
que tu financera un film autour du tout
alors pas du tout c'est pas son genre
alors je vais vous dire c'est une fille
très sérieusement si elle était sérieuse
à sa part avec toi pourquoi cette
apparente un tannage faut que je réponde
brou jouerions ont largement gâché son
là je vais justement aux géorgiens pour
toi voilà
prenez votre temps on n'est pas pressé
encore là la plupart au lieu de passer
le week-end et qu'ils ont dit
je me faire piquer les vestes en
taffetas by me tue trouvaille toi mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
là ils vont faire qu'il va faire quelque
chose tout de suite à la cadence du dup
monique va débarquer le sourire aux
lèvres
alors là tu sais pas ce qui va se passer
tu sais ce que je vais faire non je vais
partir avec avait bien sûr puis me
laisser tout seul j'avais voyons qu'est
ce que tu veux que je fasse ma situation
est délicate mais doivent appeler
l'envié d'aller pas délicat non non tu
es toi laisse moi réfléchir choix j'ai
trouvé une idée à oui je veux dire que
que je vais voir je vais voir vers ans à
paris d'un producteur à ces banques ça
alors j'arrêterai money quand elle
arrivera toujours là et qu'est ce que tu
lui dire la vérité une fois n'est pas
coutume après tu reviens ici
non j'avais l'appareil a dit que tu vas
pas me laisser seul avec toutes ces
femmes si tu t'ennuies dubois toujours
de rigueur que l'appliquer dès fais pas
ta petite amie il s'attaquera pas sur un
bouton les commandes sorti les mains tu
vois mieux alors la mieux alors là
brusquement mieux la facture sera pas
utile non non non non non d'autant plus
que je doive en b rend ce soir oui j'ai
rendez vous avec lui je vais dire est
celle de mettre à couvert de plus trop
quoi faire pour le garder à tin et c'est
la moindre des choses quand on dit que
dans ces zones de votre couvert de moins
je pars pour paris tue pas mais oui bien
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'avais
donné congé à suzanne pourquoi n'as tu
pas dit plus tôt et oui c'est vrai ça
pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas dit plus
n'ont même pas laissé le temps d'ouvrir
la bouche or tu crois que c'est
raisonnable de partir tu fais mieux de
lui téléphoner de venise
ben oui je suis dit des saloperies que
tu connais bertrand un jeu bien qu'ils
aient horreur de la voiture puis c'est
quand même mon producteur de moi de me
déplacer
il est accompagné et ne veut pas gâcher
temps week-end parce que j'ai un rendez
vous soit pas ridicule mon chéri tu ne
gâchera via les sites et les mâles est
amer ta mère qui m'a déçu et maintenant
je partirai avec vous je regarde le
feuilleton à la télévision on voit ce
que fait un moment qu'ils chérissent la
mhra en panne ne misons pas pâle et il
n'est pas dans sa peau abîmée bah moi
j'avais oui je sais que tu te dit zhu a
passé deux jours à la compacte et oui
vous en pagne est tout le temps dans la
voiture
non bien sûr bien sûr enfin si ça peut
arranger tout le monde et vie qui
profitant enfin l'occasion de respirer
l'air pur à la campagne chez l'habitant
plein sur les bois de meudon aux côtés
les enfants vous êtes bien gentil mais
j'ai aura-t-on s'occupe de bois précieux
capable de faire tout ça alors vous dis
très tranquillement
et puis vous faites pas de villabon
sujet voilà un hommage à la figure
les finissants sont accrus pictures
vient directement chasser parfois non je
me demande un truc c'est pas possible
d'être aussi
possiblement oui ma chaise
alors si j'ai bien compris ton mari va
repartir
tu entendu comme moi il va rester
couchés à paris il fera parce qu'il
jugera mieux
je ne comprendrai changé votre façon de
vivre tantôt il est à londres
tantôt à new york ou ailleurs et comme
par hasard vous êtes ensemble ils
trouvent encore le moyen de filet mais
qu'est ce que tu veux un écrivain a
besoin de sa liberté mais ce n'est pas
un jour c'est une comète encore que les
comètes chérie c'est trop fort dans un
peu d'eau plate non gazeuses comme
écrivain j'ai rien à dire mais avoue que
c'est à marie bizarre vous ne dormirez
jamais dans le même lit c'est bien
simple tu aurais un accident mortel il
ne serait même pas capable de
reconnaître le corps exagère le monde
mais non pas du tout mon soutien et moi
qui supportent tous ensemble et dès que
tu veux je suis pas du genre de femme à
faire des histoires ne sert à rien mais
mon jury à ce point là c'est de la
faiblesse trois mois d'expérience
moi je suis ce qu'il faut à une femme
pour plaire en bas dis le moi et bien
jusque 18 à elle doit avoir une bonne
éducation de 18 à 35 ans elle doit être
jolie de 35 à 45 ans beaucoup d'autorité
et et après 50 ans qu'est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elles aient de l'argent
merci du conseil mettez vidéo sans
vouloir te vexer de réputation mais il
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui vont faire un
coup est-ce que tu dois tient françois
duvalier des champagnes un garçon
charmant une sorte d'énorme et vient il
m'avait demandé de les poser est
pourquoi n'as tu pas accepter à nous
avions 20 ans tous les deux j'étais
stupide je trouvais qu'il était trop
jeune pour moi et c'est marié
non mais maintenant nous avons 50 ans
tous les deux il est stupide et me
trouve trop vieille pour parce que tu la
revue pauvres il a tellement changé qui
ne m'a pas reconnue
je voulais te dire pourtant marie agnès
mon mari tranquille et laisse mener
mulas m'a donné ma vie comme j'en ai
envie de nous amener à tout va et vient
alors sur tout piètre qualité
comment ça s'est passé abbas avait un
bifteck était pas trop dur combat
et tu sais moi je sais que tu ne devrais
pas prendre la route dans cette étape il
ferait mieux de te coucher avec un grog
des deux cachets des ce2 ça va ça va je
t'assure ça va mais si tu veux je peux
te conduire mais non je suis grippé je
suis pas mourant il faut quand même
tenir un volant demanderai de me
conduire lorsque je voudrais apprendre
des insultes de nouvelles je dis jamais
drummond non pas toi mais c'est les
autres étant dit j'espère que je ne
faisais pas fait trop mal suivi
l'artiste donné au contraire c'est très
bien très bien où leur maintenant nous
sommes intimes poèmes appelé patrick
c'était peut-être pas très prudent de
prendre la route en votre état mais si
ça ira je me dévoue déjà je tue qu'à
minuit le film se tordant huit jours je
dors mon producteur voilà c'est tout
berger rendez vous apportez un fil
les modifications apportées au scénario
comme je n'avais jamais écrit deux
pièces de théâtre ainsi une fois trop là
une fois de mauvais souvenirs pourquoi
le public n'a pas aimé non et la pièce
était tellement mauvaise que même les
comédies à partir dans la fin bon allez
je ne sais pas quelle heure je rends
travail est occupé par son bras pas
parce que et lyon mais dont on est à
mais lâche toi
la première si bercy ta sollicitude dont
je vais rater le feuilleton à la
télévision mais pourquoi ton mari n'en
veut pas bon il a horreur de ça mais
pourquoi parce qu'il estime que le degré
d'aboutissement d'un peuple est
proportionnel au nombre de téléviseurs
qu'il possède messadia du vol et vous
n'avez pas d'enfants non thomas n'est
pas ça non plus moi je le comprends dans
un sens parce que j'adorerais avoir les
enfants par exemple mais à une condition
ne pas être leur père à la c
marie curie
pas là pour s'amuser plus mon arrivée on
s'asseoir
les quelques ados de la maison
je parle chinois ou quoi j'ai demandé si
avec quelqu'un d'autre dans la maison
n'a pas l'appui que la bonne dans la
cuisine question et a cherché mais on se
dépêche
on vient vite sens achevé un carnage les
molaires à s'ils voulaient pas d'accord
c'est dans l'air mais ce n'est pas pire
la porte et puis j'ai pas attendu c'est
à dire entendu là on s'asseoir dépêche
il ya un téléphone dans la maison j'ai
pas bien compris
voilà comme ça on sera plus droitiers
l'argent ou des bijoux vous cherchez
votre mac comb et on cherche pas
d'argent simplement le calme et la paix
alors l'année dans une fille issue d'un
monastère les molaires silence au
s'asseoir si je vous tire une balle
entre les deux yeux ça vous fait rire en
fait qu'est ce que vous voulez je viens
de vous le dire on cherche un coin
tranquille
pourquoi pas est moins bien de casser
une banda les yeux je ne savais pas que
c'était si fragile tiens c'est une
banque ça vient la cabriolet à des
étrangers aussi
tout s'était bien passé on s'en est
tranquillement espèce d'abruti cadeaux
les larmes ont maintenant les routes
sont barrées la région rôle de flic on
peut pas faire 100 m sont tombés dessus
on s'est dit que le meilleur moyen de
passer au travers c'était de se planter
ils attendent que ça se passe voilà
pourquoi les ici mais on vient parce
qu'ils chauffent et d'épaves appelé sa
part cambrioler une banque comme ça mais
c'est un sans gêne les merveilleuses et
elle va baisser les bras mais attention
mon copain est sourd et muet de
naissance mais par contre il a très bon
vieux et il est très rapide de la
gâchette
ça veut dire que s'il y en a qui s'avise
de faire le malin il tirera sans
demander d'explication comme de toute
façon il est sourd le monde ça ne
dérange pas
on est d'accord et oui parfois vous
allez passer jusqu'à claude on n'est pas
pressé bah oui mais moi je suis pressé
vos joueurs à des boîtes portant
pourquoi tout de suite mon pari vous y
serez pas mais il fonctionne comme chez
soi je ne sais pas raconter pas pour les
matchs et ça y'a pas de rendez-vous qui
tienne personne ne sort d'ici c'est
clair ou alors ça sera les crises
bancaires
moi si je peux pas sortir ça risque de
faire des histoires et nous on risque 20
ans de cavale
en supposant que le président du
tribunal soit de bonne humeur alors vous
l'histoire ont fait pourquoi vous avez
choisi ma maison il ya d'autres dans les
environs n'a pas choisi se trouvait
comme ça va vu un grand parc une belle
maison
le genre de résidence où les flics on
rompt pas idée de venir nous chercher
plus comment plusieurs fois tient alors
on est rentré tranquillement vous
attendez pas puisque ça fait des années
que je vous dis de plaza chien dégage
mais vous lui coûtait rien refusé dans
les nuages
j'espère que la visite des ces messieurs
va vous mettra plus de plomb d'art à
terme écouter le brame ans
attend-on vérité c'est comme ça ne
m'enlève tout le monde
non mais sans blague
eh ben
ça peut plus attendre il faudra
non non non non
de quoi j'me mêle d'un champion pistolet
mais l'alcool lui monte à la tête
cantine à coude pour ils se croient au
far-west matière est pour un report and
on alors
19h45 devriez partie au léo mais
n'importe où ça m'intéresse pas je me
dis que les routes étaient gardés ça
grouille de flics je suis quand même
mieux ici que dehors à jouer on va les
voir alors laissez-moi sortir pour que
vous alliez me dénoncer ni tête je suis
pas un débutant
un rendez vous important croisait pas
compte de la catastrophe qui va arriver
s'il peut pas bouger d'ici j'ai pas ce
qu'il va vous arriver si vous restez
mais c'est ce qui m'arrivera si vous
sautez donc joué sous la main je suis
tranquille ou à peu près 10 dont il ya
un signal à la grille d'entrée d'une
sonnerie qui se déclenche dans l'eau par
voulez vous rendre compte de bach ou
même si je suis pas curieux ah bon on
aurait pu bavarder un petit peu joue là
bas c'est le brûler c'est pas grave
bah oui ça pourra mettre fin à la
cuisine c'est pas pour moi de se faire
remarquer moi je veux aller voir parce
que la cuisine mais puisque je m'en
excuse
ça j'étais comme ça mais ce n'est pas
vrai on croit qu'il a six autres
fourmilière justement ils m'ont fait une
piqûre dans la face comment tu te sens
moche et je suis heureux quoi kurde
d'antibiotiques
parce que j'ai la grippe asiatique j'ai
la grippe asiatique j'ai la rive
asiatique
si vous restez là où elle a tempêté
contre que je m'en fous j'ai déjà eu oui
une rechute ça peut être mortel
noël vous fatiguez pas même avec la
peste ou le choléra je rentre à la
basique bon aller surveiller votre tv ou
angers loban avec vous pour être certain
vous fassiez pas de bd mais sa la
filiale alice curieux il ya 200 millions
ancien obligé de porte plus 100 millions
et bien c'est de l'argent facilement
gagné facilement
c'est vous qui le dites vous savez que
ça fait aussi bien vous rapporter 20 ans
nourri logé blanchi sa 6ème pas de
risque on ferait que dans les banques
comme un guichet pmu un soir de pluie
mais vous n'avez pas eu peur
6 pourquoi pourquoi vous l'avez fait par
esprit de famille quand j'étais jeune en
banque qui a ruiné mon père pendant des
années on a mangé les briques des
briques creuses parce que c'était les
moins chers depuis quand j'entends le
mot banques
c'est comme si on agite un chiffon rouge
devant un taureau maintenant j'ai
récupéré le capital et les intérêts
enfin ce n'est pas une raison pour vous
en prendre aux autres banques elles ne
sont pas responsables quand on crie au
voleur dans la rue et qu'un type et 700
fuir tout le monde court après pourtant
une arrière et aux autres les banques
c'est pareil c'est pas juste c'est john
qui va mal et les autres payent matadi
bouzid où la série
c'est pas mal chez vous mais j'aime pas
le style il ya une maison meublée le
week end dans les environs si vous
voulez pour aller la voir
je vais en faire construire une au bord
de la mer tous les jours des matches
angers les moyens mais vous n'allez
quand même pas garder tout ce temps agen
non ce n'est pas vrai pour le garder le
bon dépenser bien mal acquis ne profite
jamais
surtout pas à celui auquel on l'a piqué
alors madame c'est fou parce que venir
dîner mais oui c'est une histoire vous
allez entendre pour vous avez plus tard
en judo tout cet argent qu est ce que
vous allez en faire mais en fait pas
pour ça non mais ce que moi je n'ai pas
de conseil à vous donner enfin à votre
place je le mettrais dans un lieu sûr
par exemple je pourrais vous indiquer
une très bonne banque mon fric dans une
banque pour faire cambrioler ça va pas
la tête thoracique dû arrêter de vous
agiter comme ça asseyez vous et dès 8
heures de vol en rendez vous diront que
c'est pas qu'une jolie femme c'est pas
grave ça c'est drôle
mérité gifle doit oui mais quand même on
a failli disjoncter lieu cette année
c'est déjà aidé les obligé de rester
enfermé enfin c'est vous qui avez cassé
une banque et c'est nous qui sont en
prison dit vous n'avez pas comme ça si
on va pas rester qu'un jour à manger ce
n'est leur radeau de la méduse
mais j'y pense
il faut que je sorte demain matin pour
quoi faire mais c'est dimanche
il faut que j'aille à la messe le
seigneur de le pardonnera ca qu'à force
majeure suffisait pas si dramatique chez
vous rien n'est grave
je ne comprendrais jamais votre façon de
vivre les temps changent et madame howie
pour changer ils ont changé dans ma
jeunesse on faisait le contraire de
matin on allait à la messe tous les
jours et on prenait un bain par semaine
je suis sérieux quelle est l'importance
eu mon rendez vous mais moi oui parce
que moi j'ai été élevé dans les
traditions on faisait notre prière avant
tout les pas pourquoi c'est vous qui
veut dire réfugiés
je sais pas si c'est trop ils ont
contacté écrivain une situation comme
celle là ça fait un bon scénario
le garde a déjà fait un film avec un
très bon gars et comment ça finissait
parfois qu'à la fin tout le monde était
tué j'espère qu'ils l'ont pas vu qu'est
ce que c'est que ça la grille d'entrée
qu'on vient d'ouvrir
qui sait je sais pas je vais aller boire
payez pas bougé vous attendiez quelqu'un
non mais si oui c'est mignon c'est
sûrement mais c'est sûrement une erreur
mais je viens et vois je n'étais pas
bougé quand cette personne d'autre a
fait comme si nous étions des amis
arrangez-vous pour l'expédier en vitesse
est pas de blacks ça cher dans le tas si
vous aurez la page de dire et alors ça
vous avant sera quoi combien coups de
feu tout le cycle a priori si je vais
courir le risque
bon bien écouté alors fait sortir tout
le monde et puis laissez moi seul avec
elle israël avec avec cette personne
tournon des mots dans la cuisine vite on
se dépêche angelo surpris qu'on en soit
vous pourrez je me débrouillais de sa
boîte ou daube surveiller jeu même si
justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire je me cachais là et vous surveillez
je vous donne deux minutes pas une de
plus à 2 2
tu sais pas savoir ce que je suis
content d'être arrivé je suis exténué
paris en ce moment c'est intenable
au fait ce week-end à la campagne ou de
tous ça va être mairie si d'accueil
missiles aux besoins de demain je vais
dormir jusqu'à needs you vient embrasser
mon chéri
mais qu'est ce que tu verras aérienne
c'est là la joie voilà la surprise
tu me demande de venir je viens mais il
sait que pauline surpris oui à la
solitude ça te réussit pas un c'est bien
l'arranger ici où j'ai fait visiter nom
de the brick
il va plus pardon tu dis faut du barde
pourquoi ce qu'il faut pas que reste t
il et parce qu'il faut que je lui il
faut que je reste seule mais pourquoi il
faut qu'il reste sept îles et équipé au
choix ce seul tu peux me croire sur
parole pour gérer ça va vite mais bien
évidemment je vais passer le week-end
chez les amis tu fais tout un cirque
pour que je reste à paris
je t'attends au téléphone tu me demande
de venir je me tape 150 kilomètres sur
des routes pour est la province qui se
prétendent bio j'arrive enfin mais
monsieur m'annonce froidement qu'il faut
que je parte parce qu'il a besoin d'être
seul non mais non mais tu te fous de moi
c'est comme ça qu'on voit que vous
demandez que je dois rester seul parce
que je suis contagieux j'ai la grippe
asiatique
oui oui le docteur est venu ce matin il
m'a dit windows grâce d'une mauvaise
grippe
pas une botte seul à même de ses
radiateurs c'est contagieux je veux pas
que la trappe
je t'aime je t'aime tôt pour ça tu vois
je vais bien c'est qu'on prend le nom
mais bien sûr mais mais mais je vous
demande pourquoi tu me l'a pas dit plus
tôt au lieu de prendre six heures
mystérieux totalement opaque de dire
qu'on a la grippe mais c'est encore plus
net de narnia
mais je voulais pas l'inquiéter mais
j'ai cessé mon père l'a eu
les habitants de show téléphone demain
ou après demain
pourquoi faire pour donner mes nouvelles
est-ce que tu t'imagines que je vais te
laisser seul quand tu es malade a fait
mais je suis pas un monstre mon chéri du
matrix à terme assis dans la voiture je
vais la chercher je te faut une piqûre à
dire que l'udc a fait des études
d'infirmière bien présent sur le bifteck
qu'est ce qui te parle de ça on n'a pas
besoin d'être infirmière pour faire une
piqûre et c'est moi qui faisais celle de
papa il n'a rien senti l'on n'est pas
revenu
mais bon oui le club il ya trois ans
dans un accident d'auto gabon auront
joué une tactique pas j'y suis vacciné
non je vais m'occuper de mon chéri non
non non non je ne veux pas compliquer
une n'ont pas convaincu du tout si
c'était ta femme qui te le demande est
une refuserait pas
alors ne profite pas de ce que les lois
d'ici pour faire des caprices d'enfants
gâtés au
[Musique]
au moment de rien way
elle n'est pas limitée tandis votre
maître alain le pas ne pas vous raconter
ma vie je suis obligée de l'entendre
raconter ma vie vous me dites vos
affaires c'est des réflexes de l'arbed
écouter aux portes du dre on va baisser
d'un ton un an puisque c'est comme ça je
vais reprendre les choses en main pour
mettre ces pharmacies avec moi c'est
plus faisant donc j'ai reçu je veux mais
je savais pas que tu attendais quelqu'un
je vous dérange pas du tout pendant
l'attenté aurait alors été dites moi en
venant vous avez vu des poulets dans les
environs bipolaire oui des perdreaux
vous devez pas vous ennuyer 1
des bourdes écoles des policiers quoi
mehdi des flics comme tout le monde on
va savoir j'en ai vu il y en a partout
dans le coin oui on a mis des barrages
sur les routes
il paraît que deux gangsters ont
dévalisé une banque à lisieux on m'a
même prévenu qu'ils étaient armés et
dangereux
oh je suis bien content d'être arrivé
ici mon chéri ce qu'avec trois jeunes
femmes plurielles
j'ai poussé mon éventuel pardon jeudi
venant hysteria conditions là tu es
tranquille on va vous inquiétez pas pour
moi je vais faire un tour dans le parc
tu viendras me chercher quand vous aurez
fini ah non c'était pas prudent
habitants crient il n'a pas la grippe et
le boxer que la police recherche chez
moi raconte ses histoires je ne
partirais si si pourquoi je voulais pas
que tu le vois c'est pourquoi il faut
parfois on vient te le dire à l'instant
le cancer que la police recherchait lui
si vrai c'est vrai
bon et bien puisque vous êtes entrain
milieu je m'en vais pour aller dénoncer
ici où j'ai joué sans aller on avait dit
que mariner cavenaghi qui n'est pas du
calme avant de faire chez toi et bâtons
vous le savez vous allez arrêter là j'ai
plus envie
trop tard c'est à l'heure du palais
partir beau patrick juste ordonne de lui
dire de messi sorti j'ai voulu d'elle je
sais pas qui commande
n'ayez pas peur comme ça on est pas des
assassins tant que nous y oblige pas ou
qu'est ce que je dois faire
attendez c'est tranquillement demain
matin la police devant les barrages on
partira comme on est venu tout ce qu'on
vous demande c'est de rester calme alors
caché ce truc hein ça me rend nerveuse
voilà soyez sages mon copain et moi on
retient pas se montrer mes shows peu de
copains dans la cuisine et surveille les
quais les autres dr il va vous expliquer
aux maires
les autres les autres j'en ai des amis
qui sont arrivés après ton côté les fans
j'ai pas pu prévenir maison combien wii
sont deux un couple bravo mais alors tu
parles d'un week-end tranquille et puis
il ya aussi ma est aussi ma belle belle
belle mère il est charmant
les amis à la rigueur passe mais
tabelles mer mais j'ai terriblement
gênante mais génère de poids dans tout
ça moi d'autant plus qu'elle est venue
avec sa fille sa fille
c'est un fameux cardiaque qui l'a
sûrement textes moi je vois plus rapide
mais non mais non mais non mais et elle
est au courant pour nous deux annoncés
les deux courants cette petite réserve
bien entendu elle te vois un ami fidèle
et non les comme toutes les femmes mais
pas sûr que soient fidèles ne tient pas
être sûr que le patron de peu dans tout
canada est au courant on n'entend rien
de la cuisine bon moi je m'en vais à ce
genre de situation je rêve de ça enfin
je croyais pourtant que j'étais clair
qu'est-ce que je m'exprime al ousseynou
dia de boucher personne ne sort ici
c'est compris mais je dirai pas si fish
no réduite vous prenez pour un hamburger
mais c'est toujours dit si vous courez
chez les poulets qui rappliquent et
s'emparent d'un don mettra pas y aller
tant le bruit sous la main je suis
tranquille ou à peu près at il alors on
au résumé là qu'est ce qu'on fait
bref non mais elle reste ma femme de ce
verre et on sait tout le monde le monde
reste
que c'est pas possible papa lehmann nez
à nez quand même ça me choque pas paru
le mois où on va dire à ma frontière je
te présente ma maîtresse elle croyait
qu'il restait à paris elle venus passer
le week end avec moi à la campagne c'est
votre affaire ça mon vieux on va vous
voir vous connaissez pas les femmes
peut-être mais je connais le code pénal
même si vous voulez être tranquille
c'est pas le moyen 7 se rencontrent
savais que si je les calmerait je
connais le moyen mais non je vous dis
que ça va être intenable alors envoyé
aux croyants et non me chercher on a
deux minutes on peut chercher mais je
vous empêche pas moins cherchant bien
cherché bon on va chercher ça mais voilà
là mais j'ai trouvé
et oui vous allez dire communiquer votre
ami mon ami ni personne ne l'attendait
ça passera très bien le genre
c'est pas une raison pour ma fille et si
vous préférez la corrida libre à vous je
vous dis que c'est le seul moyen pour
être tranquille
enfin quand même dit je serais à votre
place je dois plutôt flatté a gardé bon
ya pas de boeuf
bon ya pas de buzz ouais ouais y'a pas
de oui pas mal non ouais pas mal et pas
mal moi j'aime plutôt le genre transport
un peu voyez moi la carrosserie de la
carrosserie un peu longue un peu l'ombre
en main le châssis oui non écoutez c'est
pas une affaire je peux pas m'en faire
une reprise là dessus c'est pas ma
partie
monde pas de la garder dans lé sang des
pauvres au moment des ponts en dépose à
tous elle est même pas garantie à mes
diplômes c'est bientôt fini votre petit
combi alors si vous voulez trouver une
petite amie très bien tout seul moi je
suis pas dans un coin quand à toi tu
perd rien pour attendre
et en plus ça fait mal à renvoyer jouer
un rôle de proposition vient jamais à
l'evian laciné langer on dépensera le
saunier on a bien fallu pour qui l'homme
a dit toi c'est fini mais différent
pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez trouvé
celle là chez les mauves liane
mais comment calmer du gotha persona non
vous prendriez vic la diva les
participants au débat
voyez ce que ça va donner tout à leur
arrêt faisait peut-être exemple j'en
suis sûr ça va mal se terminer
je t'en prie et coûte quand même que
mettre un peu de bonne volonté quand on
attend quand même laisser les gens dans
la cuisine pendant toute la soirée ne
pas se présenter comme un maîtresse
devenait possible de rendre service
voir ce nombre doit passer ta vie avec
lui j'ai l'impression blanc faire
semblant d'être sans des médias non
c'est pas terrible à notre maillage il y
en a peut-être besoin de chercher bien
c'est bien parce que ta femme et
cardiaques est pourtant un service à mes
crois pas à ça bon alors toujours d
accord on y retrouve entre faille et non
qu'ils vont payer c'est une femme
mehdi l'on sait c'est le fils et moi je
trouve mais entre nous mais nos hôtels
luxueux je la connais par an comment tu
la connais pas renoncé c'est seulement
son ami
ouais c'est mon ami
je voulais pas garder en dehors alors
elle va rester là à mai
et il en cette fille mois
bon
je retournais dit suzanne si vous voulez
vinet ce sera à la cuisine est par
ailleurs tu viens avant dites moi mon
glav vous allez réunir ici toute votre
petite famille
non ces fêlés du moins j'espère parce
que ça commence à bien faire
dis moi oui ses deux filles cette fille
c'est pas celle que tu attends d'asie et
du golfe explique françois bien bon tu
viens viens une balade avait bien non je
suis trop mis en route de bages a pris
la même route est bonne les choix
d'apple up to tatou chance à tous bon
faut s'en prendre
ab je peux vous regardez en sinon ça
vous avez vous fait merci c'est
dangereux à votre métier non pourquoi un
fait mais j'ai vu le film à bonnie and
clyde
vous savez le cinéma quand il va
travailler vous allez avec lui non je
tricote au coin du feu
vous êtes mariée avec lui on va leur
sûrement pas je peux bien vous garantir
que je suis pas cette petite amie pour
très longtemps dans remarquer je vous
comprends ce n'est vraiment pas drôle
tous les jours d'être la petite amie
d'un bonhomme et vous moi je suis l'ami
de celui qui est debout là il est gentil
pas méchant et qu'est ce qu'il fait dans
la vie c'est avant qui est généreux au
moins apprendre aux assistés et pour le
reste 20 pas terrible
là aussi il faut insister le dos il est
déformé par son métier et l'emploi tout
le temps des termes comptables des
termes comptables et du genre je suis
difficile de vitamines cette nuit là
j'ai la pince à profit ses pertes
le vous être habitué ça finit par être
heiner brand
oui je vous comprends
je ne fais pas marie de 20 sur mu et ça
me coupe la pire
vous allez rester ici jusqu'à quand ah
c'est le cieux qui décide
heureusement que je ne suis pas émotive
hommage en connais qui en seraient morts
surtout c'est pour votre fille que c'est
dangereux
pourquoi ah ben tout le monde sait que
ce genre d'émotions c'est très mauvais
pour les pour lui mais oui on s'y attend
pas et brusquement crac crac
tenez par exemple classe bb la vedette
américaine
ça lui arrive et tout d'un coup kl argué
mais il est mort puisque je viens de
vous le dire
alors pour votre fille cette attention
pourquoi elle complètement idiote
on va apprendre à dire 7 l'autre et
voilà comment on dit on pas dit de
combien je voulais vous prévenir cette
les attentions à quoi la petite amie du
gangster et les folles elles aussi mais
vous vous avez ce qu'elle est un nom que
le père de ma fille c'était clar guide
félicitations bizarre clark even
l'acteur vous ou cassoulet dans autant
en emporte mais oui enfin vanessa bell
dans l'idée que je me suis laissé faire
un enfant par un artiste de cinéma
non ça sur mon corps
voilà vous voyez combien ça fait
prononce enfin il est formidable
voilà un grand merci merci vous pouvez
pas là il est vrai il sort de la banque
non merci sans façon bon bah si vous en
voulez pas moi comme je le dis toujours
l'argent il faut le prendre là où il est
absolument on s'en souvient pas de
différence entre un banquier un gangster
banon
ainsi vous allez tout le rallye vous
allez coucher ici vous croyez pas que je
vais sortir en pleine nuit c'est plein
de voleurs injuste coin tranquille alors
nous venons on n'est jamais trop prudent
quand on a un petit capital
ah bah moi je voulais dire le mieux
c'est de le mettre en lieu sûr non mais
vous allez dormir ou dorment urnes hors
murs pas question de dormir je vous
disais allez toulon d'aller au resto
chez pour monter aussi non je reste
oui il va surveiller nord le premier
pour certains idéaux de nos ballons
banon bastille ont bâti non alors non
parce que moi je ne peux pas dormir les
petites fermes et voilà j'ai dû comme je
te ferait clairement chili 2 1 allée du
moura les moines se rasseoir sur le
divan non j'aurais trop peur de quoi
je suis là à attendre on doit peut-être
trouvé un aliment mademoiselle là haut
il n'y a plus rien mon chéri brillant de
quoi je me mêle qu'on pouvait pas quand
même l'obligé à coacher sur le canapé
l'a nommé du temps c'est votre ami
reviennent
gmail est sisi le rap mais on peut bien
on pourra en grevette redire ma
belle-mère de décembre ça permettrait à
mademoiselle de monter à les bouger
j'aimerais que dans le premier la tâche
même par terre et pourquoi vous êtes mon
avis non et alors
alors je m'efforce de sérieux je suis
votre ami d'accord ce morceau du calme
non mais je vous préviens c'est mon
petit chicherit
en ce moment j'ai autre chose à penser
qu'à la bagatelle mais bien heureusement
pour vous je vais chercher une
couverture et je me sentais sale et on
se dépêche
allez mes coups ne me fais pas d'effort
peut enfin alors on n'est pas bien ici
c'est une bonne idée les flics qui
viendront jamais cherché voiture
allemande doit maintenant partir après
et ils montrent comment je sais pas on
verra
edit dont la fille là qu'ils s'aiment
voilà vendront ouais c'est la petite
amie du type qui est marié on a raconté
un couac au 2a femme va surveiller
dehors mais dis donc oui il faut
vraiment je passe la nuit dehors
pourquoi tu es le meilleur il est j'ai
plutôt une meilleure place dans le lit
de la bonne la petite sud ouest j'ai
l'impression qu'elle serait pas contre
ssb a crié le nom c'est moi confiance et
les autres mais les autres ne bougeront
pas son bar de peur the way
je n'oublie pas tes sourd et muet c'est
meilleur moyen d'apprendre des choses
n'inquiète pas je dirais pas à mon
à part
[Musique]
c'est la fumée vous gêne je peux le
talent à tous la lumière vous dérange
pas pendant bien me dérange pas
195 millions j'ai piqué 195 millions au
lieu de 200 hauts ces banquiers ont
annoncé tous des voleurs
[Musique]
raté
on se
croyez bien c'est comme ça car il veut
accident jeter sur wii 2 ou 3 fois tu as
grenier continuent à dormir alors j'ai
pensé que la lumière du jour se
réveillerait pour de bon tiens la revue
tu as très bien heureux et quand je
dormais pas c'était très bien aussi bon
gîte de ses fins tu vois pas un petit
café pas que je vais briser avec du lait
et trois sur
les premiers les autres qu'ils pouvaient
sortir ça va du reste la france avait
bradé gens voient ça s'est passé pour
toi comme ça et toi vous et sean les
autres ne sent pas encore descendu
or que le pot je me demande pourquoi je
me pose tous ces questions il est sur
les nouvelles la ville marc du cinéma
parlant sa vie est un coup dur pour vous
disait qu'il voulait c'était les sous
titres
bonjour vous avez bien dormi ce coup-ci
coup sauf moi j'ai dormi comme un ange
doit faire un léger déficit de vitamine
un petit café vous faire des virages ou
usage si vous voulez vous préparer le
petit déjeuner
suse art s'il vous plaît oui vous plais
paris les petits déjeuners
oui messieurs y comprenez quelque chose
vous qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous les deux
et ça crève les yeux
ils ont passé la nuit à sable vous
croyez à témoins avec un sourd muet
meadows
alors non seulement ont fracturé les
banques
non seulement c'est un produit le fort
chez les années des gens mais en plus on
joue les séducteurs et aux dépenses non
dits voyous
je pense tu me retienne vous foutez une
bonne trempe à dos pour vous apprendre à
vivre qu'un faux pas vous fatiguer vous
avez bien qu'il est sourd muet bah vous
savez s'il était pas sourd je dirais pas
tout ça
jeremy johnson qui s'en vont ils ont
prêté mon rasoir j'ai horreur qu'on te
sers de mes affaires
alors ma chérie malgré tout ça retient
passé une bonne nuit au val très bonne
camillo depuis longtemps alors si j'ai
bien compris j'ai vu la seule à dormir
dans cette maison
et là j'arrive janvier et bonne petite
tasse de café et on s'en va au site
l'ouverture des bars même le dimanche
faceo 30 ans jurent entier je vais aller
m'installer à l'étranger attend et le
soulevé par avait tout bien sûr la
nonette travailleurs qui se lèvent de
bonne heure et qui se couchent avec le
soleil
pas seulement avec le soleil la nuit n'a
pas été trop mauvaise
excellente oui le divan et bien pour une
personne que ça veut dire
vous voulez des précisions non son corps
que ça c'est là la grille d'entrée qu'on
vient d'ouvrir
j'attends le quelqu'un dont vous êtes
sûrs certains je connais bien angers lui
et moi on va aller se planquer et on
vous surveille
on sera partis tandis vidéos youtube est
le premier qu'ils ouvrent je tiens dans
le tas vous n'êtes pas de quoi toi je
l'emmène aussi on sait jamais
s'il ya plusieurs banques dans la région
nous allons refuser du monde
vous désirez police comme ils serrent
d'envié brigades mobiles à la police je
suis patrie bilingue et en santé je
passais dans le quoi j'ai vu votre
maison avec c'est une maison qu'on
remarque beaucoup je suis anglais
contraire un petit coup d'arrêt à une
maison dans laquelle on entre beaucoup
aussi
vous prendrez bien quelque chose que me
sais pas pas dans le service
ah bon parce que parce que vous êtes au
service oui je ne sais pas si vous êtes
au corps mais on a cambriolé une banque
à 30 kilomètres d'ici non pas possible
on regrettera que les commissaires
vivait quelque chose à à moins que vous
ayez déjà pris votre petit café mais
assez effectivement j'ai pris mon petit
verre de vin blanc réveille comme
d'habitude
alors comme je vous le disais on a
cambriolé une banque dans les environs
ça alors c'est incroyable une région si
38 mais qui qui a pu faire ça de
gangsters on les a vus s'enfuir on pense
qu'il se cache dans un camion vous
n'avez rien remarqué d'anormal
et qu'est ce que vous appelez la normale
bah je ne sais pas des gens qui aurait
filé en vous voyant la personne n'a fini
en voyant
des rôdeurs dans votre part non personne
n'a mis le nez dehors depuis hier soir
j'ai reçu mes passagers à la messe mais
pas chiant pas de chez nous il va
acheter un
je ne vous demande pas s'ils sont entrés
ici c'est bien que ce serait idiot un an
trop tard au delà l'air de rien pas
présentés sont des gens dangereux mais a
tous pensé dont ils ont pris 300
millions en billets de banque
vous avez dit combien 300 millions bien
sûr directeur de la banque et de l'onu
ils n'ont pas perdu un petit peu en
cours de route
quand vous le voyez monsieur le
commissaire s'était maison calme
paisible dans laquelle il ne se passe
rien la trame est passé maintenant
habitués dans son bail le elle fait
floquer un canard en plastique et je
suis tranquille on les pendra bon bien
sûr on les pendra parce qu'il parle on
parce qu'il parle avec toujours ce
qu'elle s'accomplit par exemple voir et
vous êtes sûr que salah parleront
certains l'idéal
voyez vous ce serait un voleur murray
avant leurs vues et revues c'est à moi
jamais
essai de la pente il ne parle pas il
faudrait un miracle quand même on n'est
pas loin de lisieux dans les miracles à
busan dit pas vous êtes bien patrick
villardier et les faits valent police et
moi même mais il ya une chose que je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas que
vous puissiez lire des histoires
policières sans connaître ces gens là on
veut que c'est une question
d'imagination c'est pas la même chose
quoi une supposition
admettons que nos deux hommes est
débarqué ici brusquement ici et si dans
cette pièce dans cette pièce the dial
métaux je sais bien que ce serait idiot
est ce que vous dites est validé s'ils
vont faire ces questions que tous
visaient à vous et écrivez un peu
d'imagination et bien je crois qu'il ne
ferait rien comment rien non je pense
qu'il nous garde serait enfermée sous la
menace d'un revolver
en attendant que ça se passe ah ouais
voyez c'est ce qui nous fait rigoler aux
hôtes du métier quand on voit
l'invention des écrivains et chercher
des choses extraordinaires alors que la
réalité beaucoup plus simple ça veut
dire quelque chose mais je vous en prie
mais pas vous vexer n'est pas du tout
pourquoi parce que vos n'y est pas du
tout mais alors là pas du tout moi je
vais vous dire comment ça se passerait
sa voix de velours vous servir dans
votre métier bien sûr il entrerait il
vous fallait 100 dans la cave
il vous alignerait contre le mur et là
tu as ta ta ta ta ta ta à la
mitraillette
je vais vous dire quelque chose monsieur
le commissaire vous n'allez pas vous
vexer
mais nombre quoi parce que vous n'y êtes
pas mais alors pas du tout
ce que vous dites est impossible
pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya pas des caves
dans la maison alors
date jeudi la cape comme j'aurais pu
aussi bien dire le douanier capable
d'éliminer la cuisine la cuisine on
faisait des paras place des patrons dans
la cuisine d'ailleurs les domestiques
n'aime pas qu'on ait toute la journée
sur leur dos à ses supporteurs de this
is a dit moi je me suis relevé pas
établi des barrages sur les routes
voilà on les a enlevées ça fait les
embouteillages ah bah oui pour défaire
commissaire bien je vais rentrer au
commissariat faire mon rapport à rien
dans sap désolé de devoir vous aider
mais intelligent comme vous l'êtes vous
allez sûrement les trouver
les gentils chez vous oui à haut et très
gentil quand je prendrai ma retraite je
me ferai construire une maison au bord
de l'eau pourquoi ce que nous avons des
amis hier soir pied qui nous disait la
même chose et surtout vosges à lui et
moi on sera peut-être besoin
ils vont loin dans la vie vos amis sont
des collectionneurs connexion des
portraits avec pascal des lattois cornet
je vois je vois pas où il en fait une
affaire qui a pas mal réussi
une affaire qui a bien réussi très très
bien réussi et bien déplore d'être
prudent hauteur de nos jours il est
difficile de garder son capital a
atteint qu'il double ils sont prudents
nature serait plus tard être ni monsieur
villardier oui auriez vous l'amabilité
sans vous déranger de me faire visiter
votre belle maison
ben c'est à dire qu'on va juste un petit
coup d'oeil vers la cuisine par exemple
mais vous savez le ménage et pas faire
je ne tiens pas parce que vous ne roulez
pas un mais ce commissaire je peux vous
dire quelque chose quelque chose qui va
vous intéresser
figurez vous que ce matin revenant du
village j'ai croisé deux hommes sur la
route y courraient ma personne mais
alors il savait les rudement près ces
mêmes qui disaient par le tracé idiot
l'année penseront pas toujours 19e
non ils ont pas dit c'est idiot mais
mais un grand mot que je voudrais pas
répéter les nuls et pourquoi vous ne
l'avez pas des plus tôt enfin moi je
vous écoute ai parlé c'est tellement
passionnant ce que vous racontez vous
avez 6 admirait la bonne de monsieur et
madame et il était commandant de zone
il y avait un petit gros et puis un
grand maigre avec une moustache
moustache noire
c'est ça qui est formidable c'est donc
avec moi expérience
et il y avait une tache de vin derrière
l'oreille après pays pourrait bien
obliger pas eu le temps de regarder
derrière les saints cette fois non jeudi
c'est frôlant une vieille connaissance
un spécialiste des banques
je vais donner des instructions pour
conserver les gars que tu avoues c'est
pas beau diable et oui oui vous allez
sortir
j'allais sortir d un pyjama oui c'est
juste pour faire un petit tour dans le
jardin ben oui pourquoi pas
bonjour tout le monde d'harry ça va
mais tout ça me regarder comme ça j'en
avais fait pas payer papa noël je suis
de la police commissaire d'envié mais on
a cambriolé il manque dans la région et
si personne n'était au courant mais je
n'ai pas de chance ils ont filé ils ont
fillettes ont pris le train qui craint
les madmoizelles oui mademoiselle
suzanne dubé l'abri ah bon mais pourquoi
ce que vous ne l'aviez pas dit on va
vous le dire elle ne savait pas on ne le
savait pas mais qu'est-ce que vous ne
saviez pas que c'était des gangsters
moi je le savais je ne le savais pas
mais c'est comme ça qu'un mal à la
mairie qui le commissaire chercher de
gangsters mais ne savait pas que c'était
les deux hommes suzanne a vu les deux
hommes et ne savais pas que c'était les
gangsters
alors tu en as commencé à nous a dit
qu'il y avait deux gangsters et que je
suis à vie avait dit qu'il y avait des
hommes
nous avons tous voulu que les deux
dexter et les des hommes qui font que tu
n'en faisait qu'à
cet appareil
c'est lumineux et lumineux comme est
d'une clarté aux rites aveuglant bon eh
ben moi je leur tourment prendre un bain
avec mon petit canard ça me repose je
vais monter avec lé fiche de tout les
charmants robe elle est intelligente
savait pas de doute
bon eh bien vous voulez ce monsieur
commissaire joe bon merci de votre
visite
je les connais qui ça allez auxerre
avant ils vont essayer de finir
l'amérique du sud fera rêver mairie et
le concorde et cette dame mais c'est
rien c'est ma belle mère est toujours
comme ça est toujours sauf la nuit quand
elle dort jamais eu envie de re des fois
même
delabrière gay rien rien rien bon et
bien excuser moi encore vous avoir
dérangé
quelle chance vous avez le pouvoir
passer un week end tranquille comme ça à
la campagne et je paierais cher très
cher pour être à votre place au revoir
merci suis avant de rien mais si oui
est-ce que vous allez chercher tout ça
question d'imagination comme tu me si
elle est formée de la défense
ils sont quand même dans les pubs ont
oublié votre père quand il est allé au
delà de quoi perdre la tête
si vous tendez lui comme ça c'est le
procureur qui s'en occupe
en fait la pièce qu'elle joue son père
noël alors il est ici j'ai un conseil à
vous donner éviter les cas bon vous en
faites par les plus malins que une passe
quand on n'a jamais été arrêté une patte
riche en eau ils croient qu'ils ont à
faire les spécialistes
je leur souhaite bonne chance non mais
dites donc ce frelon dont parle m comme
ici à vous connaissez vous si c'est
celui auquel je pense ça fait deux ans
qu'il est au venezuela allait enfin pour
la malaisie
la valise ne l'est pas il n'est pas fou
remuer naturellement et parler en temps
comme tout le monde
alors cette valise je n'ai pas moi où
est elle bon ça c'est toi qui l'a enfin
tu vois bien que je n'ai pas un mot non
plus mais plus que tout à mes yeux enfin
je te dis ce n'est pas toi tu n'as pas
d'en pousser sur moi et cela qu'ils ont
apprise on ne regarde et vous qu'allez
vous jouer en prison les piquer 200
points qui voulait que je me calme usées
bushman moi je vous dis enfin alors
qu'ils auraient coûté pas bien jusqu'ici
j'étais gentil mais maintenant ça va
être un manière forte
tout doit donner de l'eau du bassin
alésien
j'ai failli car je m'en fous rires
il y en a un look a pris la valise on
sait pas encore lequel mais on va savoir
du tout pour qu est ce que vous prenez
vous croyez qu'on s'est donné tous pâle
pour vous apporter 200 briques à
domicile et comme à partir des mains
vides sans rire
alors si je retrouve pas la valise je
vais faire un sourd et muet la vraie
c'est est labellisée au but l'ancien
meneur s'entendent comme le rappelait le
prévenu assez clairement
il dit qu'on lui a pas de raison et moi
je dis que c'est forcément là debout
personne ni entrée ni sortie a parlé pas
me sèye et si lui il avait trouvé ont
alors entendu chanter je suis sûr c'est
lui comme en suisse et celui non mais ça
va pas non monsieur pour manon à l'eau
gelée par me david moyes le coach ça me
fait même pas comment les fêtes ça donne
des bonbons mais je je vais vous
descendre à titre textures ça sera un
très mauvais exemple on a écouté enfin
quoi alors je vais dire toi j'aurais
mieux fait de me casser une jambe un oui
est revenu à chez toi de quoi vous
plaignez vous allez finir à l'hôpital à
nous annoncer que mon chat dit quelque
chose
merci bon pour amener ça va pas
l'acheter pas touché jeté en l'air bien
sûr fait ben ali de quoi je fais pas
l'idiot on entend rien quoi d'horizons
bien surfer poudre dans les oreilles il
entend rien voyez ce qui arrive un peu
de vous voyez gerber ce qui se passe on
attirait oui moi je tuerai comme un
avertissement pour avertir de quoi je
suis en retour pas la valise je vais
faire un carnage c'est pour la valise
fallait le dire
j'avoue parler mais je veux pas parler
je veux mon argent et mandat les jeux
c'est will hayes vous mes valeurs dites
le je vous le dirai mais quand nous
serons seuls pourquoi selon vous verrez
bien avant noël téléphone enfin mls je
sais où est la valise mais je lui dirai
quand nous serons seuls bon vous avez
entendu la dame de paris tout seul tout
londres accusent ils nous connaissaient
chemin l'enquêté près
on voulait pas que je reste avec l'eau à
londres et à temps pour les jo edwards
la baguette est vrai juillet à les blues
mandingue départ maintenant
naturellement il paris entend tout le
monde alors pourquoi vous faites tous
ces chefs
parce que les sourds tel poussière dans
l'oeil ont la parole
j'ai compris tu me jacques surveiller
les autres voilà mais tullow à nous de
maintenant moi je rêvais set value sont
doucement doucement je ne vais pas vous
la rendre comme ça c'est l'oubli l'avais
prise bien sûr cette nuit vers 4 heures
du matin j'ai une soif je suis descendu
boire un verre d'eau et en remontant
j'ai pris la balise où j'ai gonflé j'ai
rien vu sur votre état c'était difficile
j'ai dû m'endormir les nerfs ont lâché
du côté nerveux vous aviez l'air pour
toi en forme parce que vous nous parce
que j'ai battu mon et peut-être frappé
un long très long
vous pourriez peut-être faire ça
ailleurs que sur mon canapé bon alors
qu'est ce que vous voulez une part du
gâteau
votre argent ne m'intéresse pas bon
qu'est ce que vous voulez je veux que
vous restiez ici une semaine c'est une
semaine mais pourquoi faire ce que vous
avez fait cette nuit ce que j'ai fait
cette nuit
non me dit oh on vous croyez chez les
bourgs grillades au numéro privé ça j'ai
beau faire ça toute le nuit dont on voit
là des manières
j'aurais jamais cru ça tu voulais en
roulant mais non je veux seulement que
vous restiez ici une semaine c'est tout
pour rien pour rien pension complète
non j'ai nourri blanchi non il ya
quelque chose qui va pas quelqu'un comme
vous ne font pas quelqu'un comme moi de
le loger et de nourrir pendant huit
jours
il ya un coup fourré quelque part vous
êtes méfiant mais bon tu pas pour
affaires si vous y tenez absolument je
trouve que mon mari a besoin de repos et
alors vous les joyeux bordel en janvier
tous les soirs en restant ici vous
l'empêcher de sortir
je m'occuperai grèce vous voulez que
l'oiseau restanques arranger c'est moi
qui dois l'enfermer quelque chose comme
ça alors je suis désolé mais vos
problèmes conjugaux m'intéresse pas du
tout dommage mais manger mes soucis
tout le monde a les siens j'ai pas le
temps d'occuper les mots n'ont pas non
plus il faut pas m'en vouloir mais non
retrouvez jean mallot de moyens sur nous
bon allez à temps voilà je suis ravi de
vous avoir connu ghetto plaisir pourquoi
guitare et aurait facilité la liste
qu'elle va ghz alors qu'elle valide ma
valise à la belle est là où dans le
placard au premier elle est vide
quoi jeudi elle est vide
les 200 millions ou est-ce que vous les
avez mis dans un autre endroit
quel endroit je ne vous dirai pas
pourquoi je vous ai proposé un marché
vous restez je vous rend l'argent vous
refusez je le garde
est ce que vous foutez de moi bonito
soyez polis avec une dame
une dame une dame qui piquent de
sanvignes hommes ne sont pas à vous j'ai
travaillé dur pour les avoir bon rester
tranquillement chez vous apporte le
paquet vous voulez le garder alors dit
on alors vous vous demandez mon argent
je me sens immédiatement si vous mettez
vous ne savez jamais où j'ai caché
l'argent que vous n'aurez pas un sou
même pas de quoi payer votre avocat je
trouve à bien tout seul il ya quatre
chambres trois salles de bains d'office
une cuisine sight placard 12 penderie
sans compter les coins et les recoins
que je suis seul à connaître et 10
hectares de parc en cherchant nuitées
jour pendant trois mois vous avez une
chance et encore c'est pas sûr mais si
je vous tapez thurgovie mais je me
mettre à crier les audiences ne savent
pas du goût il y aura des blessés et
peut-être même des morts la police
viendront vous arrête les battra massawa
bas 2 jours 8
huit mois et coûté 6 parce que c'est
vous mais je manque de mots ça va ça va
bon je reste huit jours mais c'est bien
parce que c'est vous il y a autre chose
encore il ne faut pas que mon mari sache
que vous restez à cause des mois mais
qu'est ce que je vais lui dire mais ça
débrouillez-vous mais s'il apprend la
vérité pas s ou hépatite
vous parlez d'un travail c'est facile et
tout ça pour garder votre pari sous la
main et dans les bonnes femmes n'étaient
rien répliqué et où les hommes quand on
vous laisse trop de liberté on est tu
n'avais style canton plus dans l'espace
à ses envies et une emmerdeuse si vous
croyez que c'est facile
bon je vais aller chercher les autres
dans huit jours
vous demandez mon argent et qu'est ce
qui prouve que vous allez pas me jouer
une entourloupette pas dit 'je suis pas
une voleuse et non bon
venez là pour faire un c'est terminé on
veut qu est ce que ça veut dire
tous ces mystères là pas de mystère la
propulse terre j'ai décidé de rester
quelques jours de plus
j'avertis c'est la maîtresse de maison
c'est normal pas des souffrances non
vous avez décidé de rester quelques
jours de plus peut-on savoir pourquoi
oui rabat bien sûr les gars sont
surveillés bon alors comme moyen pour
partir d'ici avec la route
j'ai pas de voiture mois elle va prendre
est la mienne qu'est ce que c'est
une bentley boys le jeu par les
anglaises
j'aime que les italiennes pénale est
très bien assuré je vous laisse tout le
temps filer et après seulement je porte
plainte pour vol plus dense et pas très
honnête tout ça
abattus dont vous me parlez paraissait
mal placé pour parler de les tuer mais
je suis bien placé pour rester alors
joué 8 soit et or on veut vous allez
rester le cas mieux de jour en 2 ou 3 5
mn à on va vous croyez dans un hôtel si
je viens je m'installe mais vous est un
drôle de pistolet un pistolet du papa
didot attention à parce que moi j'ai mon
bureau alors à paris au matin on attend
on attend c'est fini on meurt j'sais pas
vous voyez dans les eaux
c'est pas l'annapurna le dit mais qu'est
ce qu'il a fait
tu me fais et je te dirai pas la fête je
tends mais tu te fais mal m'en du canal
la prochaine fois c'est sa boum ça fera
mal pourquoi moi parce que si elle
essaie de s'emparer je veux dire une
balle dans le vent en poupe et pourquoi
toujours à moi parce que vous n'avez pas
de chance
j'ai bien compris vous
si yann acquis et les balades c'est lui
que je descends à toi alors tu pourras
dire tu as mis dans de beaux draps
alors tout va alors coiffé on l'a fait
allons-y de la valise toi et moi toi et
moi on reste à bompas plus non voilà la
classe pour la police la police
maintenant pourquoi tu voulais partir
tout à l'heure où la loi kill des
fatigues étoiles comprend rien
bon c'est des cons pris soin d'informer
la valise ou est ce qu'elle était t'es
sûr d'un bon si ça doit continuer comme
ça je le défends mais c'est pas parce
que vous avez vous avez caché l'argent
ici est alors sa calandre à une fois les
portes je vais vous le dire mais
attention à leurs ancêtres complicité de
vol moi j'aime pas ça du tout et du club
band radial je reste en temps si je
trouve l'argent je vous le rappelle je
donne à la police il ya quatre chambres
trois salles de bains le plagnard étudie
la penderie lot cinq offices et 15
hectares de parc ar 10 10 alors en
cherchant bien nuitées jour pendant six
mois
vous avez une chance de le retrouver et
encore c'est pas chic est sûr c'est que
j'essaie de vous voir vous me dites donc
c'est fini oui j'ai dit que je restais
je reste ou non mais de la viande à tous
les repas du boeuf
j'ai pas le temps pour le petit déjeuner
café au lait et tartines beurrées écrié
un sucre ou de sucre 3 s'il vous plaît
est l'un de mes cousins viable c'est
tout du coup encore non c'est pas tout
un jus d'orange frais et glacé non mais
sans blague c'est moi qui connaissent et
je le répèterai pas
non mais sans blague
merci oui c'était ça y est saluée par m
[Musique]
je te pose là
parmi ces non dits
waouh
[Musique]
a bien dormi
pas mal
m
tu as toujours le scot et la très bien
tina et diplômes bongo les bleus mais
comment l'accès à faire à part manger
dormir non je me renseigne cambraye
certain temps partout dans deux jours
encore deux jours
mais pourquoi pas maintenant la police
tu as police woman ou non et qui quoique
vous êtes passés en italie est bien on
est pas mal aussi
onze journées assez de cette vie en
commun tu te sers du rasoir de
villargoix des affaires de sa femme
quand il n'y a pas moyen d'être
tranquille cinq minutes on va l'être
tranquille j'ai lu une revue qui
traînait par terre hier ça me donne une
idée pour faire de l'argent au nom tu
vas pas recommencer un nom une fois ça
va mais pour que ça devienne une
habitude mais non je vais acheter une
est là oui ça on lâche des côtes du
chili en amérique du sud
quelle drôle d'idée non parce que sur
cette île il ya du guano et qu'est ce
que c'est des grandes voies d'eau tu as
attendu d'avoir 200 millions pour
contempler des crottes d'oiseaux et
o'shea encore non mais tu crois pas que
nous qui jouons nous y sont capables
d'en faire de si belles non non tu
comprends pas et je comprends que tout
cet argent se monte à la tête
écoute moi là bas il ya des quantités et
d'oiseaux des millions et des millions
oiseaux qui se nourrissent de petits
poissons qui vont prendre dans la mer et
il regagne faire leurs petites crottes
toujours au même endroit sûr d'eysines
aulas voulait ça finit par faire des
mètres et des mètres et des mètres
d'épaisseur est alors alors ça s'appelle
du bois nous on le ramasse on prend ça
très cher l'un qui faillit y ait des
gens qui paient très cher des crottes
d'oiseaux koopmans comme non mais il y
en a qui font fortune avec ça c'est le
meilleur des engrais et tu mets ça dans
les champs la repousse deux fois plus
vite et les vaches donnent trois fois
plutôt les tissus j'ai lu ça dans une
revue scientifique parce qu'il ya de
sérieux mais alors le lait de vache
oui avec des crocs d'oiseaux
y compris un je prendrais du lait en
boîte maintenant tu sais ce qu'on va
faire
pourquoi on s'en va pas j'en profite
pour me reposer un petit peu que tu vois
tu as fait c'est du repos tu n'arrêtes
pas de faire ménage et c'est tout juste
si on prend pas pour le larbin tu
rigoles haies des jo c'est un tout petit
peu le temps ils sont morts de peur elle
sortait voulait monter mon café au lait
s'il vous plaît donc non mais sans
blague
et puis quoi encore
un jus d'orange et dépêchez-vous
l'histoire voilà voilà c'est parti ça
lui
sir keith ont marre de beurre alors on
peut rendre service nous ça va très bien
merci
tous ces gens si je peux le dr te parler
pourquoi vous aviez parlé là bas tu peux
me tutoyez nous sommes tous salle non ce
n'est pas nécessaire ah bon il t'a dit
quand il partait qui ça de même à signer
dans deux jours
tu peux en avoir assez bah oui par
dessus la tête a offert y aller en
patience tu n'as plus pour très
longtemps
non seulement des fiches de jeux wii
écoute pour thuir oublier tous ces morts
vivants mort je t'amène avec moi au
kenya pardon oui mon prochain film the
town acadien s'amuse avec moi non merci
tenez prenez s'en est sorti lui à la
cuisine commandant merci t'as pas envie
de connaître le kenya si seulement j'ai
pas envie de connaître avec vous aux
pumas en veut encore pour ce petit
incident de semaine dernière parce que
nous fourrer dans l'idéal ou trop vous
abaissez un petit incident
oui mais d'après bonnie alors bottes
fourrées dans le lit de notre ogre pâtes
froides en liesse c'est différent telle
chose remarquez j'ai pas me plaindre je
pars pour le chili nous sommes au chili
la wii et des crottes d'oiseaux
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
la mort c'est clair non j'accompagne
maxim nucci dit maxime tu vas me dire à
l'instant fermé par dessus la tête de
vous tous mais pas de lui je comprends
puiqu'il à 200 millions se trouvent
séduisant
allez vous tombez bien moi non plus je
confie mon ami vous en profitez pour la
séduire l'amener à l'ego me confier
notre ami dit plus tôt vous étiez
drôlement important que vous en
débarrasser ali pour quelques jours
encore tout le temps et alors
fallait pas courir le risque je reviens
moi non plus demander aux intrus cité
ici logés nourris dans le clip a dont
elle a choisi l aelies mon nom est libre
et les personnes est libre ici à part
susan dans son propos d'elle pour faire
les courses jorat les concernent
voyez que monique n'osais pas votre
genre d'échangé la ville un usage à
usage ben maintenant vous allez partir
et puis tu sens un show de danse à la
police n'ose y compris
c'est fini de jouer les terreurs
maintenant parce que j'ai pris d'entrée
voltaire à bravo gardez le au cod et je
veux des gens c'est la police
et qu'est ce que vous leur direz tout
vous est arrivé ici vous avez menacé
quand on est obligé de vous garder
menacé avec quoi je n'aime pas d'armes
et les 200 millions que dans les vallées
où est ce qu'ils sont mais bien la
police et trouvera et ben alors a bien
de la chance mais vous le savez ce que
je leur dirai moi que vous êtes bon
complices l'ont recèle rencontres seront
déclinés au combat mais steam croiront
parce que moi la nuit je réfléchis mais
il vous était contenté de réfléchir
encore et vous savez ce que je leur
dirai que j'ai choisi une banque extrait
de chez vous tout près pour pouvoir me
cacher plus facilement faut et quand le
comici à la venue de josé maria di bello
que tous les jeux 10 preuve que vous
étiez dans le coup depuis six jours moi
je suis logé nourri considéré comme un
avis hilary l'argent l'argent je vous ai
demandé de cachet j'ai tellement
confiance en vos cheveux brûlés
et angers l'angelo angelo un pauvre type
complètement sourde inquiète amoureux de
la balle pour bernard yade est la bonne
ah oui pourquoi dorion des lobes voilà
yade est la bonne parce qu'elle était
persuadée que son patron recevait chez
lui un vieil ami je suis un honnête
citoyen mois jamais condamné
pas de casier judiciaire mais en plus il
faudra expliquer la présence de monique
et ça ça vous embête radieux la police
vous prendra et votre femme vous lâchera
et vous servir la péter parce que vous
êtes trop tarder oui quel prix vous êtes
de ce genre d'homme qui trompent leur
femme pour s'apercevoir à jour ce sont
eux qui sont trompés parce qu elle est
charmante votre femme comme on est les
ravisseurs venaient pas de piquer ma
femme aussi non
croyez moi vous ne dirai rien et dans
deux jours je serais parti avec monique
tout un beau [ __ ] oui il te fait pas
mal là où je porte plainte
d'ailleurs évaluez vous les empêchez de
sortie on est séquestrée je suis des
vôtres
on voudrait bien parti on peut pas on
peut pas
[Rires]
c
messaline quelques d'orange
oui j'avais jus d'orange voilà voilà
c'est dans ce type sur le dow à nantes
de jouer trois parties avec son ami ben
j'espère qu'ils vont en curieux curieux
qu'il parte
un nom curieux qui partent que dans deux
jours
deux jours c'est facile il voit toutes
ces émotions plutôt que je sais pas
cardiaque trop content que tu dois
chercher l'actu de ces idées alors si
maxime jeu je trouve plutôt beau garçon
oui et son ami est tout à fait charmant
leçon qui vont très bien ensemble
sans parler bien dans son corps bien
dans sa rue à cause de ton travail
et oui oui c'est pour mon travail ça
nous donne l'occasion d'être tous les
deux oui c'est tellement rare ainsi à
marc richard quand tu es là toi tu es tu
es une femme ravissante comme le disait
encore il n'ya pas longtemps
il ya bien des mois qu'il n'a pas dit ça
ouais
là j'ai une idée mon prochain film se
tourne au kenya système est avec moi
mais tu es sûr que je ne te dérange
réparé venant pas du tout moi j'y
pensais depuis longtemps dit il faudrait
que j'amène noël au kenya
deux brevets il ya tout
sans permis nous irons sortie dia tous
les deux
tu le sais ne pâlit son service et
maxime alors dynastie constaté en forme
dans la sonnerie de la grille elle
fonctionne pas à pas dans les casses et
au fait j'ai pensé à vous j'ai pris des
entrecôtes et d'hydrogène bonne nouvelle
j'entends mieux jours à vivre tu te dis
je suis ravi c'est pas encore tout à
fait ça quand maman tu as retrouvé
l'argent banon si j'étais toi je
laisserais tomber ça va pas la tête si
les avait expliqué gainey il est écrit
et les gentils votre ami dommage que
vous le kit y est enfin je le quitte
plus je vais l'épouser il m'emmènera au
chili en voyage de noces et où est ce
que c'est le chili est bien là alors là
le chili c'est loin mais c'est très loin
mais moi je vais boire un verre de lait
par cas si ce régime là continuent à
huit jours ou dépose mon bilan est avec
lui ça se passe via la pologne a pas
d'affolement qu'elle a fait des armes
afin salle stimulerait plus tôt je ne
peux quand même pas dormir avec une
mitraillette fut l'oreillette
non mais vous verrez un jour vous
rencontrerez un homme qui vous plaira
parce que j'aime ce genre viril un
meneur d'hommes tenait juste comme le
vôtre et pourquoi ce n'est pas un meneur
d'hommes à lui c'est plutôt un tueur de
femmes
non mais vous avez pris votre petit
déjeuner nom est bienvenu je vais vous
préparer quelque chose de délicieux mets
dans la cuisine oui voulais lui dire de
venir j'ai à lui parler hockey maxime
au japon beaucoup ça
la dernière fois c'est des formes
demande de rester une semaine gta vous
avez pas changé d'avis tu sais tu en as
non ça va pas non ça va pas recommencer
lui jour ses bijoux
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
baisse vos enfants quand vous en aurez
non je vais vous rendre votre argent
j'espère bien mais maintenant ah bon
pourquoi mon mari par pour le kenya
il m'a demandé d'accompagner j'ai plus
besoin de vous j'ai bien connu un bon
goût je vais chercher l'argent
monique je dois nouvelles on s'en va
quand tout de suite que c'est trop de
pauvres ça va je n'aime pas ma vie
largué son mari elle part pour le kenya
alors on va les laisser un peu seuls
tous les deux mais pourquoi on s'en va
biologie oui non mais depuis ce matin
j'ai l'impression d'être dans une agence
de voyages
je vais me ranger l'eau le déficit
serait de lui faire comprendre noël
vient de m'annoncer que vous partiez oui
elle mène par pour le kenya
oui patrick lui a demandé de
l'accompagner mais moi je n'aime pas
beaucoup ça il y a des lions des bêtes
sauvages et n'a alors plus vite qu'elle
orphée vous dérive rapport à une peau de
crocodile un tel que je le connais
m'apportera plutôt en crocodile vivant
c'est pour votre fille là sont ça va
s'arranger oui ça va beaucoup mieux
avant et vous ou allez vous dans un pays
où il ya du soleil de la lumière sur
1000 peut-être plus d'aller acheter
maison non pénil entière lui c'est mon
rêve vivre nue sur une île parfumer avec
sa part suivi d'un gros coup de fleurs
non des crottes d'oiseaux
en plus tu compares to à la campagne ne
manque pas une petite crotte par ci par
là chine où j en aura aucune sein des
mètres et des mètres 10 mètres
d'épaisseur ah oui presse des clubs
d'oiseaux ont comme ça rice mais vous ne
saviez pas c'est parce qu'ils mangent
des petits poissons que l'ère de pousser
clivages sont dus l'aide d'un voyeur
mais ceux qui détournent adulé je me
demande pourquoi je n'y avais pas pensé
et votre ménage cela fait pas bien [ __ ]
laveur
les baleines ont du poil aux pattes
tu ne peux pas rester huit jours de plus
je te répète non écrite veut dire moi je
n'ai plus envie de mandat mais bon c'est
vrai quoi on est bien ici
la cuisine n'est pas mauvaise bon la
peau grasse nos têtes n'est pas mauvaise
puis c'est calme on n'entend pas un
bruit non mais tu es devenu complètement
fou ou quoi
j'ai dit elle devient complètement fou
non pourquoi non c'est parti le premier
jour ce n'était pas la même chose
j'ai pris des habitudes mois d'ailleurs
cette info c'est neuf
ben oui la valise qu'il ne pouvait pas
la surveiller au utah usa et phonique
mais toi tu la surveillaient avec aaron
président je faisais le sommet je le
faisais pas le paralytique
et puis moi je laime cette fille et ben
bella avec tout mais elle ne veut pas
aux causes de l'argent il dit que c'est
pas honnête alors non seulement il est
devenu sourd il est idiot en plus mais
comme je ne veux pas lui faire de la
peine mais l'argent dans nos pages te
laisse tout oui tout est comment tu vas
manger à ma fille travaille doit
travailler
tiens la langue choc au cerveau on peut
rien voir de l'extérieur mais je te
laisse je vais donner un coup de main à
tout ça cela va mettre tes tablier
alors j'ai profité du fait que mon mari
était dans son bureau pour aller
chercher l'argent mais il a disparu
comment ça il a disparu a déclaré
quelqu'un d'une preuve d'achat veut dire
que t'es pas bon je vous dit pas que je
rêve c'est pas vrai ce que j'entame une
major je reste pourquoi parce que je
veux mon argent et même prenez le il a
disparu
qu'est ce que ça veut des prix non
madame maxime il avait rangé dans un
placard et quelqu'un l'a du produit il à
distance vous êtes sûrs certains
et vous auriez à terre alors prouver
sans sage qui offrit que facebook avait
fait le coup et je veux bout des lances
assez comme ça oui mais vous allez voir
manille oui des gens descendent et aux
autres aussi
alors pourquoi y avant la maison bon je
suis pas nouveau
mais des maisons passives avait caché
l'argent dans un placard disparue
l'argent a disparu à tout jamais comme
l'un des tubes de fauchon mais c'est
peut-être le vois plutôt avec vos
carottes d'oiseaux
mais décousu passé alors que non alors
patrick ne t'énerve pas s'il te plaît
quoi chez moi chez toi qu'appliquer
d'argent pour le mettre en avant moi
enfin quand je veux prendre de l'argent
ou agi mais la manière l'effort moi j'y
comprends rien
non ça vous ou michele facebook et
l'argent pensez vous ah oui c'est moi
vous voyez bien que c'est moi mais
laissons lui qu'en paroles
qu'est ce qu'on fait cet argent vous
l'aviez mythe dans quoi si maxime n'a
fait ni dans une grande serviette de
bain les six pack a quitté dakar se
limite qu'au début pour donner aux tats
huriez c'était dans la machine à laver
jean paul est complètement
ça va
le déranger
et vous
les avait pas vus les deux hommes n'ont
jamais non stands et ans parce que
frôlant celui que je suspectais il est
parti pop pour le venezuela
vous avez un gros paquet zoo du débat
bille est une sorte de la banque
monsieur commissaire y en a au moins
pour 200 millions de noms vient des
comptes et lui est acquis tout ça et je
le prends le montant du vol de la banque
vous êtes sûr je suis certain doubler
vos tibias c'est vous qui avez fait
comme avant vous pourrez de plus intime
ce commissaire alors c'est qui c'est lui
c'est monsieur c'est monsieur qui vient
de les trouver dans le dans le fossé le
long du mur qui borde la propriété
pensez vous monsieur maxime laurent tu
es mon conseiller technique
oui il voulait trouver dans le aaa
une trentaine de mètres d'ici ouais
c'est inouï pourquoi ont-ils abandonné
donc peut-être pas fait exprès là on
peut dire que vous étalonner tome on
peut toujours le dire elle est beaucoup
qui auraient gardé l'argent oui moi
aussi et tu aurais fini avait en
amérique du sud par exemple vous pouvez
me diot ou omelette rue je peux vous le
montrer sur le commissaire je peux vous
le montrer yves ollivier le suivi de ce
commissaire je vais vous montrer
il arrivera s'est passé pas loin faites
attention soit parce que les bains mais
qu'est ce qui t'a pris mais pourquoi tu
voles la vie président a dénoncé il nous
aurait accusés de complicité de recel
ou alors attention vous avez bien
compris le commissaire fait pourquoi
vous l'avez tout normales a annoncé il
comprendra suffisament va vous expliquer
alors le commissaire on s'en tient à
cette version
c'est maxime qui a trouvé l'argent dans
le fossé faut dire ça sans ça va on est
tous dans le line up est quand même je
trouve que maxime s'en sort très bien
or ce sont 103 bien peut-être pourquoi
au fond il était passible hicham ça oui
on remarque la raison qu'un par exemple
pour monique oui il aurait très bien pu
dire oui les migrants et ironique mais
il aurait pu inventer n'importe quoi
j'ai soir que vous tapez un brillant de
soins possibles dont tu ne sers à boire
gérer oui
attendez madame c'est vous aider merci
monsieur villardier pour maximum je vous
arrive vous ne voulez pas que vous
gardiez un mauvais souvenir de votre
séjour ici vraiment j'ai pas de chance
alors là vraiment je n'ai pas de chance
on m'aurait lycée cinq minutes de plus
je le décide et qui parle plus de maxime
le décider à quoi et je le décide et à
me confier son argent
je veux lui donner 1 6% à tirer parents
et moi j'ai travaillé le tout à 24% tu
pense qu'à ça n'allait pas boire un
verre et allez voici l'équipe d'aller
braver la bombe vient d ouvrir le bout
des chambres genre allez on attaque ne
sont pas jouer avec ça c'est dangereux
héritiers blessés répète pour voir j'ai
blessé c'est formidable c'est plus sourd
c'est moi monsieur le commissaire je ne
savais pas que valverde changé et nous
sortent et je les trouvais avec l'argent
là dans le fossé au lieu de vous montrer
en temps oui mais j'ai vu ce qu'ont
donné j'ai besoin de parler à monsieur
je voudrais que vous étiez seul nom
motive aussi et vous aussi
alors les gens sous les noms
alors eh bien il ya d'autres déjà pas
mal et fait 200 millions c'est pas de la
cre d'oiseaux je vous le fais pas dire
vous êtes et le conseiller technique de
monsieur lui l'année oui conseiller du
coin chargé de documentation de bon les
films un policier avant et je sens que
je pourrais vous passer des tuyaux à
bander il ya sûrement des trucs que vous
soyez s'est pas donné la mort par
exemple je peux vous dire comment ils
sont entrés sans déclencher la sonnerie
d'alarmé
il termine mon fort quand je vous
l'expliquais vous ne me croirez pas le
chef était géniale plus tôt ils ont fait
le tour par derrière
ils ont vu le soupirail et pour rentrer
une ancien bar où je vous arrête ils ont
scié trois barreaux maintenant vous
allez me suivre au commissariat
pour quoi faire et vous pensez tout de
même pas que vous allez vous en tirer
comme ça alors ça serait trop beau on
veut bien ou payer la prime mais venir
la chercher
la prime quelle prime ah oui pourquoi
l'assurance donne une prime de 10% à
celui qui trouvera l'argent c'est bien
vous qui l'avez trouvé ses papiers
tourisme a dit ce qu'on censure 200
millions ça fait pas millions c'est tout
même pas mal c'est mieux que rien et en
billets qui seront bons parce que cela
personne n'aurait pu les toucher il
était fort ils étaient tous marqués
alors au premier paiement crack qui se
serait fait et malgré on le savait pas
je vous jure que non non non
voyez oui je sens que j'ai encore des
trucs à vous passez du temps attendu
chéri bas mais non on va pouvoir faire
le tour du monde en attendant de faire
le tour du monde venez avec moi au
commissariat j'ai encore mon rapport
après d'accord je vous accompagne et
vous voulez oui l'habitude
alors je passe je passe devant
commissaires alors racontez moi c'est
intéressant
vous pouvez sentir bon ils sortent ils
sont partis oui monsieur
bon ça va il faut pourquoi vous être
achetés madame engagé comme gardien
preuve des paiements chez ryanair vous
regardez notre naissance et guillaume
gardien tu aurais pu quand même
programme yeux vous êtes débarrassé de
mauvaises habitudes oui monsieur
d'ailleurs suzanne et moi on va se
marier
et puis vous savez avec une maison
isolée comme celle là on n'est jamais
tranquille
alors maintenant un tenait ce matin j'ai
entendu à la radio que des gangsters
avaient dévalisé un fourgon blindé à
quelques kilomètres d'ici
et on les a punis mais non ils ont
réussi à s'échapper grand penser ils
étaient une dizaine
vous savez pas ils ont pris 800 millions
puis 100 millions l'appartement au jour
de noël
bonjour la famille qui veut soigner
parier qu à l'oral une maison ne sert
jamais deux fois de suite de refuge à
des banques
voilà tu croirais j'en suis sûr ouais on
dans les rangs bas vers là je suis bien
placé pour savoir si steve enfin j'en
suis sûre aujourd'hui dans la réalité ça
n'arrive jamais
est ce que ça n'arrive presque jamais
la pièce que nous avons joué pour vous
et de chance tu as
les corps sont d'européens
les costumes de donald cardwell
la vie dans la mise en scène et de
michel pourquoi
tony libre il dit
catherine amaïzo
jacques l'intérieur
marie-claude mais ce trail
christiane jean
katia tchenko
à lormont b strahl
luisa calle peine
dormir
cette brutale
[Musique]